deep in the heart of Ireland lies a
little known food company called Gambia
you probably never heard of Gambia
before but chances are you definitely
have consume their food products because
every single protein powder protein
shake protein bar every healthy version
of junk food like high protein instant
Ramen almost all of them get their
protein powder from Gambia Slim Fast
optimate nutrition iso pure body and fit
think Amazing Grass all the protein pows
you see on Amazon they all use Gambia
wayy protein powder which allows this
company to Rak in more than $4 billion
in Revenue a year and you might be
wondering well okay Jake sure they all
get their protein powder from the same
place but what's wrong with that protein
powder is amazing it's the key to
gaining massive gains it's so convenient
since I don't have to cook I can just
chug down multiple protein shakes a day
high protein smoothie Bowl that's
perfect for post cookout or breakfast
what's up M Nation this is the high
calorie bulking smoothie you need to try
this winter season telling you man I've
been doing this for years this is how
it's done perfect shake when in reality
you should feel guilty eating the stuff
because most protein powder is actually
terrible for you when you're taking a
food product mashing it up concentrating
it down you're concentrating those
dangerous metals that means these
products contain an abnormal amount
relative to what a healthy diet might
have this time they bought 137 of
Amazon's top selling protein powders and
sent them to a lab what they found was
alarming various toxins in your
supplements so where are you getting
your your you know protein and stuff
from how how are you
that's fake see every time you chug down
that silky smooth protein shake you're
ingesting a whole cocktail of toxic
artificial chemicals and ingredients
chemicals like Asis suan potassium an
artificial sweeten Nerf found in diet
soda that's been linked to Thor damage
in animals natural flavors a glorified
term for MSG and soy leian a thickening
agent made from genetically modified soy
beans that contain estrogen that's great
for muscle building right yum and all
those plant-based protein patterns that
aren't made from disgusting animals well
those plant-based prot proteins are even
worse with third party test showing that
they're filled to the brim with things
like heavy metals and glyphosat-prozess
horrible put in cream put in Sugar it's
a Hershey bar well when in reality most
of these protein products are no better
than ultr processed foods in fact most
of the time they are one and the same
stay dangerous and let's get into
it so you're this guy Bob Hoffman in the
early 1950s you make a living selling
old exercise equipment like weights and
whatever this thing is but selling
exercise equipment in the ' 50s isn't
exactly a booming business people come
in they they buy one set of weights and
you never see those customers again
there's only so much equipment a single
customer is willing to buy but you have
big dreams and you definitely didn't
want to be just another modest equipment
salesman so if you were going to get
your Fitness Empire off the ground you
would need another products something
that your customers could buy over and
over again something they would get
completely hooked on that they will
always need more of and that's when your
good friend Professor pra brag told you
about the potential of the supplement
business there were all sorts of
supplements out there to make up for
people's worsening diets but the idea
Professor Brad gave you wasn't just
another supplement to keep people
healthy what if you could create a
supplement that helps people build
muscle that promises L their dream body
massive PC and RI apps included and that
was how the million-dollar idea of high
protein food products was born I mean
protein certainly does help with muscle
growth and eating a giant steak or a big
chicken breast is a pain consumers
deserve something convenient something
they didn't have to cook something they
could just scarf down super quickly to
get their daily dose of protein if you
could come up with something like that
they would buy over and over and over
again so you started formulating you
started with a good helping of dirt
cheap industrial grade soybean meal
which was normally fed to livestock but
to you it was the perfect base for your
new high protein food but soybeans have
fats so you added some toxic solvents to
defat the soybeans after all we can't
have fat and food for Fitness freaks
remember and being that this was the 50s
when solvents and food hadn't been
reviewed by the FDA yet you could use as
much of these toxins as you wanted so
with the base of your protein food
product in hand now all you needed was
something to cover up the taste of your
little soybean meal concoction and what
better than some sugar packed Hershey's
chocolates just pour that right in and
boom high protein food in a can this
would be the Revolutionary formula that
you would push to the masses and yes
soybean flour doeses cause flatulence
and hives and soybean flour does
increase estrogen the hormone when too
high especially in males can lead to
problems like infertility low
testosterone slow growth shrinking
muscle mass and weight gain where one
cup of soybeans has the equivalent
amount of estrogen as 20,000 cups of
chickpeas which seems to be the exact
opposite of what you want if you're
trying to build muscle but whatever the
quality or the source of the protein
doesn't matter all that matters is that
you can slap that 90% protein label on
your products and that people can chug
it down without having to cook so you
put your high protein food in every
magazine and newspaper you call it a
miracle food with a formula that was
overseen and approved by doctors and
scientists only there were no doctors
and scientists but putting that in your
ass sure sounded great before long you
and other protein powder Brands would
partner with famous bodybuilders to tell
the whole world that your protein powder
was the reason they were so muscular
that your protein powder not the insane
amount of steroids that were using were
the key to all these massive gains this
was the origins of today's obsession
with protein products now that the
public believed that a bag of defatted
soybeans or a bag of powdered milk could
turn them into this they were hooked and
suddenly the market became flooded with
protein powders of All Sorts from all
different brands so if you wanted to
keep your protein and power growing you
were going to have to make some changes
to your formula you were going to have
to find a way to differentiate yourself
luckily it didn't take long to find your
next bestseller a protein powder that
you were convinced would be better than
your soybean mulch ever was a protein
powder based on one key ingredient
[Music]
way you missed a day a week maybe even a
month that's okay you've all seen whey
but have you ever wondered exactly what
it is well whey is the watery byproduct
from cheese making and turning that
watery by product into whey protein is
actually pretty easy all you need to do
is filter out the sugars and fat out of
the way dry it and you're left with a
pure milk protein powder but making whey
protein is kind of expensive unlike
soybeans milk cost a lot more and you
need a lot more of it to make your
signature whey protein powder so as a
giant protein company like Optimum
Nutrition or Muscle Milk you knew that
if you were going to sling this miracle
powder to the the masses you would need
to find ways to cut cus so you and all
the other popular whey protein Brands
started to get a little crafty with your
formulations instead of using expensive
pure whey isolate powder which is at
least 90% protein you started using
something called whey concentrates whey
concentrate only has around 34% protein
but it tastes even better than the
isolate and plus it was Dirt Cheap cuz
the USDA defines weight concentrate as a
protein coming from we that's between a
four of 25 and up to 89.9% protein that
it's reclassified as wheight Protein
Isolate it's not the manufacturing the
science and all that it's just the level
of protein content that distinguishes
between concentrate and isolate so you
have this range of concentrates that's
as low as 25 up to 89.9 that's so
compies will go out there and they'll
put whey protein concentrate and what do
they buy they buy WPC 34 whey protein
concentrate 34 which is 34% protein it's
garbage what's the other what's the
other 66% the only problem was one scoop
of away concentrate was not going to
give you that coveted 25 g of protein
that you knew your customers wanted
second you want to add your favorite
protein powder that has at least 20 to
25 g of protein you needed to increase
the protein count somehow while still
keeping your cost low so that's when you
found your star ingredients synthetic
amino acid powders see the way the FDA
measures protein content in Foods is not
by the actual protein counts they still
use this ancient Tesla was invented in
the 1880s where the protein content in
food is measured by how much nitrogen it
had not by how much actual protein in it
proteins all contain nitrogen so this
was the easiest simplest way to get an
accurate measurement but plenty of other
things could have nitrogen in them too
things that weren't protein but were
also much less expensive so knowing that
the FDA only really cared about the
nitrogen content you simply dumped a
bunch of nitrogen-rich amino acids like
toine and glycine into your protein
powder and boom the protein count went
up on paper without the extra costs your
new formula ended up being a simple mix
of whey concentrate also known as
powdered milk nitrogen Rich amino acids
and maybe a tiny sprinkle of real way
isolates now the average consumer will
look at that and the scoop size will be
so damn big they're not going to buy it
so what the company will do is they'll
take WPC 34 mix it with some 60 maybe
and mix it with some wpc80 that's why I
said it's a proprietary blend in itself
so there's a norm out there an industry
standard where they're blending two to
three types of weight protein
concentrate and the idea is to get the
cost down as low as you can but keep the
protein right up at that level so that
there's compliance with the consumer and
the results it's scoop of protein powder
that says it has 25 g of protein in it
it might only have like 12 g of protein
and so with your protein level sorted
you now have the perfect high margin
products to sell to the gym rats but no
matter how well you were going to Market
your protein powder there was no way
anyone was going to buy it if it didn't
taste good and powdered cheese water on
its own does not taste good so next up
it's time to jam this powdered cheese
water with a bunch of cheap toxic yet
tasty
ingredients
[Music]
so now the powder is inside the flow it
and then give it a 10c
shck all
right so that's for the normal way pow
the first thing you got to do if you
want people to buy your products is you
got to make sure your protein shake has
that silky smooth texture that makes
people feel like they're splurging on a
milkshake hold on that's going to cost a
lot of money how are we going to give
your protein shake that perfect creamy
texture with without breaking the bank
why with seed oils of course all you got
to do is shove in all kinds of different
seed oil additives like soy lethan an
emulsifier made from soybean oil and
creamer which is a blend of sunflower
oil and modifies food starch never mind
that these seed oils have been linked to
cancer heart disease and Alzheimer's all
that matters is that you get that
satisfying silky smooth texture but now
that you have the texture down what
about the taste cheese water and Seed o
may feel silky smooth but it's still
going to make people Yak on its own
which means you need some flavors to
Jazz up your protein powder and make it
taste like Fruity cereal or cookies and
cream or chocolate cream egg but how do
you get your cheese water to taste like
chocolate cream egg when there are in
fact no chocolate cream eggs in your
protein powder simple you use an
innocent sounding ingredient called
natural flavors natural flavor sounds
great it's natural it adds flavor but in
reality there is nothing natural about
the natural flavors that you see listed
on every single processed food out there
take brownie batter flavor protein
powder for example to get that brownie
batter flavor you use natural flavor
and sure the natural brownie flavor may
have originated from a cocoa bean but up
to 100 chemicals can be used to process
that cocoa bean into the perfect natural
flavor chemicals like benzoic acid which
is a compound found in natural almond
flavor that can literally kill you if
you eat too much one study found that
mice fed natural butter flavor had a
higher than normal chance of developing
lung cancer but no one's going to buy
your milk powder unless it tastes like
cotton candy so throw those chemical
flavorings into the Vats so now that you
have the texture and the flavor
optimized now it's time to sweeten it up
[Music]
Notch you got to turn your protein
powder into a craving an addiction and
the only way you're going to do that
besides the natural flavors is by
putting in loads and loads of sweeteners
you'll add in sweeteners like auling
pottassium and sucrose the stuff they
put in diet soda even though sucos has
been linked to a 67% higher chance of
developing diabetes and Asos sopan
potassium is known the cause obes in
mice but hey they sure are cheap and
those plant-based protein products well
they're even
[Music]
worse according to a thirdparty testing
Group C the clean label projects these
plant-based protein products are full of
toxins like heavy metals and BPA BPA is
literally a chemical that's banned from
plastic production but if it finds its
way into plant-based protein powder
that's perfectly fine but it gets worse
the researchers also found that 75% of
the 53 plant-based protein Brands they
tested had measurable levels of lead and
one protein powder they tested had 25
times the allow limit of BPA it's not
just heavy metals in BPA that's swimming
in these plant-based protein patterns
another group called The detox project
tested eight of the top selling
plant-based protein products on Amazon
and guess what five out of the eight
pows tested had some levels of
glyphosat-prozess yeah that is in your
plant-based protein and the crazy part
is that even the organic plant-based
protein patterns have glyphosate in them
the organic PE protein Brands had more
or about the same amount as the
conventional on top of that these
plant-based protein patters are usually
sweetened with a hefty dash of stevia
and Stevia sounds pretty healthy I mean
it comes from an herb but it's actually
just as bad or maybe even worse than
synthetic sweeteners one studies showed
that rats who were fed Stevia show
reduced testosterone levels and
testicular atrophy not great for people
looking to become stronger but who
actually cares about any of that another
study showed that Stevia can cause major
imbalances in your gut bacteria so the
problem is that Stevia and most of these
artificial sweeteners there's another
paper I will show you from nature
looking at sacarin a aspartame and
sucrose are all disrupting the gut Flora
they're disrupting the way the gut Flora
communicates with each other which leads
to imbalances in levels of different gut
flora and in this paper they didn't look
at glucose intolerance and people who
are eating Stevia but they did look at
at Quorum sensing which is the way that
bacteria and your G communicate but in
other papers in both mice and humans
they show that these other artificial
sweeteners in the nature paper I will
show you they did not look at Stevia
will cause glucose intolerance worsening
of your insulin sensitivity by
disrupting the gut flora and to top it
all off plant-based protein is just not
the same as animal-based protein the
amino acids and animal-based protein are
just way more bioavailable than those
found in plant-based protein among many
other
[Music]
differences
just take a step back and think about
how convoluted all of this is we pay
probably 10x the price for left over
cheese water that's been dried diluted
stuff with a bunch of seed oils natural
flavors and artificial sweeteners that
are all wrecking havoc on our hormones
and causing more damage than good when
we could have just avoided all this
nonsense and just ate more meat like
we've been doing for hundreds of
thousands of years a quality ribeye or
some ground beef has all the best
protein you could have ever asked for
without all this nonsense while being
jam-packed with prettyy much all the
micronutrients your body needs in order
to function Beyond just building muscle
and as long as you're getting quality
grass-fed beef or even pasture raised
chicken from your local butcher or
deliver from a farm you trust like white
o pastures you should be good creatine
is still worth it just make sure you get
it from a quality brand but if you want
the convenience of a protein shake
without all the artificial nonsense raw
milk is your friend it used to be that
all the milk we drank was raw for at
least the last 9,000 years until they
started pasteurizing milk in the mid
1900s and now all the the milk you find
in your grocery store is a shell of his
former self it's been heated up and
pasteurized which kills off all the good
bacteria that your gut needs today raw
milk is even illegal in most places
because it's all of a sudden dangerous
should we be including raw milk into a
healthy diet it is a big debate in the
world of nutrition in Michigan it is
illegal to buy and sell unpasteurized
dairy products in response to the raw
milk movement retail sales of raw milk
are banned in about 20 US states us
fedal law banss the distribution of raw
milk across state lines in final package
form while things like Ultra processed
foods glyphosate and all the other
actually bad stuff we're exposed to nope
all of that is legal so that should tell
you everything you need to know about
raw milk so don't shy away from it
another benefit to raw milk is that I'm
lactose intolerant so I've never been
able to drink pasteurized milk but raw
milk I have never had a problem
digesting raw milk the problem is raw
milk can be really hard to find the
penny on where you live so if you want
the next best thing you want to check
out colostrum colostrum is basically
super raw milk colostrum is the first
milk produced by a mother cow after it
gives birth and since this is the first
milk a baby cow has fed it is the most
nutritious milk way more nutritious than
even just regular raw milk it can
strengthen your skin rebuild your gut
bacteria keep your immune system strong
among many other things and conveniently
it comes in a powder chrone powder is
basically what protein powder should be
and the brand that I recommend is
Miracle moo the sponsor of this video
what I love about miracu is that it has
none of the terrible additives that we
talked about in this video there's no
natural flavors no sweeteners is
literally just pure grassed colossum
powder along with amolin which is a
special type of protein that increases
how much of the nutrients and colostrum
that your body can uptake it basically
makes Miracle Moon more effective than
anything on the market and all it takes
is just one scoop a day to be clear this
is not meant to be a protein shake or a
replacement for getting protein for
Meats this is just something that you
want to add to your diet because of all
the extra benefits it gives you I've
been drinking Miracle moo for the past
few months and I've really felt a
difference I've had more energy I'm
digesting my food way better so you
should definitely try and if you use the
link below you'll get 10% off on Amazon
so scroll down click the link below and
try Miracle moon
[Music]
now